he locks the doors and he goes you're
not going anywhere he's like oh no we're
going back to your place to cuddle
you're not going anywhere
[Music]
hi I'm destiny hi I'm Tyler hey I'm
Emily hey I'm Sean and today we'll be
comparing our dating app stories like
99% swiping no I'd say 40% just usually
I give people the benefit of the doubt
honestly when I used to use dating apps
I don't use them that so much anymore
but when I did it was a joke so I would
just literally swipe through everyone I
don't think that's a good representation
like swipe yes yes why yes and everyone
I was always very picky so I would swipe
now on people but then I swipe right on
the ones that I should miss wipe right
on like some situations I did message
first but if you feel like oh you just
feel it oh yeah if there's something
that their profile makes you want to
talk about then you'll talk about him
I rarely message first if he's super
cute meets all my criteria seems like
husband material which like there's not
a thing on these apps and learning but
it's very rare usually I don't say
anything and I just wait for someone to
send me you up what you do when you come
through I wouldn't message first very
often unless somebody that I wanted to
message me did in it and I would do it I
usually don't message first like it'll
take a lot for me to want a message
first like you got to check off all the
boxes
I received messages a lot when I was
active on them I I honestly didn't
receive that many yeah I think women
just respond messages from like
everywhere yeah oh yeah man it's pretty
rare I'm not sure like super
good-looking I'd say I received messages
maybe like two messages a day kind of
like a slow and steady trickle it's very
inconsistent so like one time I was
holding up like seven conversations at
watch which was a lot but then other
days it's like I could go a month
without getting a single message and I'm
like whatever it's fine
datings not a failure for me not too
many of them too creepy
I won't lie good I think just to start
off with like probably men are usually
the creepier ones in the situation yes
so I haven't had too many creepy dates
but one weird thing that happened once
was I was on a first date with this girl
and halfway through she asked me if so
how do you feel about incest and like
why and she got into like her interest
in certain animes and manga that revolve
around incestual plots and she just had
this fascination with like forbidden
love which I guess kind of makes sense
but you know I I would rather you just
stick with like Romeo and Juliet I think
there's a difference between forbidden
and illegal yeah gorgeous gross that's a
shame so this was my freshman year of
college
this guy messaged me on an app and I was
like okay fine I'll give you a chance
it's late at night it's like 8:30 9:00
p.m. and we're walking through this like
so super terrifying there's no lights
there's no emergency systems to call if
anyone got in trouble and I was like so
this is like door a and he was like yeah
yeah and I was like okay I trust you
you're like a third year big mistake
because we ended up on the other side of
campus I was like okay well I wanna come
on ago now he said that's like called
his friend and his friends stopped
driving for uber and picked us up and I
got into a car with the two strangers
and trusted them to not kidnap me
and so I had them drop me off at like a
roundabout near my door he was like oh
is this your dorm right here and I was
like no I live way over there I'm just
gonna walk and so I walked around back
to the other side of my building I'd say
one of the creepiest experiences I've
had which happens a lot when you're on a
dating app is guys you'll like match
with someone and then they'll message
you and then you're like yeah I'm not
really doing this they'll find you on
Instagram or like Facebook or something
it would be like hey we matched on
tinder yeah talk to me now and it's like
a huge red flag and it should never
happen and if you're one of those people
you do that stop because it's weird as
hell it is and that's like the risk of
dating apps too is that just from like
your name and picture guys can find you
on all these different sites too I met
up with this guy and I usually like
don't do stuff like this but he's like
how about we just like take a drive and
we can just like talk and get to know
each other or whatever and I was like
that's different like sure so he picks
me up you have a nice car he's like
works in the medical field and I'm like
okay like maybe I did something right he
got money he got money he parks the car
and he's just like playing music and
later that night had plans to meet up
with girlfriends for drinks so I was
like hey I'm gonna call my uber pretty
soon here he locks the doors and he goes
you're not going anywhere and I said
he's like oh no we're going back to your
place to cuddle you're not going
anywhere uh and like I said I'm really
nice so I was just like my heart's
beating at this point really fast and
I'm like I'm already called me my
rideshare it's on its way and he was
like that's too bad starts the car he
drives away from my waiting over at that
point I was like I have a knife and
pepper spray in my purse and I'm not
afraid to use it if you don't let me out
of this car right now either they pull
out the knife and was like let me out
the car he stops the car rolls his eyes
lets me out the car I slam the door get
my uber and I'm just sitting in right
you were like what the wait that could
have been really bad
I could have stabbed someone tonight I'm
having like anxiety right hearing that
mama is always prepared okay don't get
in the car with strangers period
[Music]
we show up at the movie he shows up late
so I'm sitting and I'm like are you
watching a movie he comes with a small
child and I was like oh is this like
your brother he's like this my son and I
was like cool cool cool cool he leaves
me with the child for like 20 minutes of
the movie and like a little kid just
looking at me and I'm just like he also
tried to like kiss me during the movie
and was like putting his arm around me
what the kid in the middle no like
there's nothing story over to another
man I met he was like hey I'd love for
you to come to my event with me and I
was like sure we'd have a great time
great night he's a gentleman the whole
night I forget to bring a jacket at the
end of the night he's like hey you can
just wear my jacket home and I was like
I think that but I'll return it to you
in the morning like thank you so much
the next morning he texts me he's like
hey so I gave you that jacket so you owe
me and I was like what do I owe you sir
he was like you know what you owe me I
don't know what I like you can have the
jacket back he's like no I don't want it
now he's like you know what I want it's
just like Lord why me listen men are the
rudest people I've ever met in my entire
life Beach it really does pain me that I
am attracted to them sometimes I went on
this date with this guy one time and it
was like one of my first tinder date
ever
yes he was like just really fooled
himself he did the the creepy thing
where he stalked my oh yeah but it was
like after we had been talking so I was
like I can kind of give this a pass
because I'm kind of into it but it was
like aggressive okay like he was
commenting on like pictures of me that
he thought really cute and saying like
like commenting like we were already
like dating at the moment I was like I
guess this is all right anyway so we go
out to this like restaurant bar he's
like being really like offensive and
like talking he's like unloading off his
family trauma on me already and it's
like the first day and then he like said
the r-word a couple of times like really
loudly and I can't say it tell me it's a
bad word and so that our word about you
said bad words like yelled it at least
three times every
it was like God like as soon as he
started just like you know it was a
therapy appointment for him I was like
okay like I'm done so the day ended up
going well on my end because I stopped
caring in terms of like what we're
eating he was like okay so like we'll
get the cheapest beers on the menu and
then we'll split the cheapest appetizer
which was like a cold sausage and so I
think the total bill like everything
over it was like $15 and so which is
fine $15 and so the check comes and then
he grabs it and then he's like slowly
grabbing it and I'm like and then he's
like yeah so like you know the day like
here's the you know the part where like
I'm gonna be like this chivalrous man I
like grab the cheque and then and then
you being like this liberal cool lady is
gonna say do you I said this out loud
yes yes sit it out loud and then I was
like are you trying to act like get me
to ask you if you want to split this $15
check this dollars yeah
but then he was like yeah cool great
let's split it and I was like am I not
worth $15 to you like my friends have
like Botany lattes that cost more is
this a date and you like will be in
really [ __ ] like weird about it and
then he just proceeded to show me his
favorite YouTube videos for like 20
minutes I was like I gotta go so I don't
normally give out my number on these
dating apps but I matched with this guy
and I was like okay fine whatever like
we've been talking for like three days
or something he was pretty tiring I was
like whatever all I'll give you a chance
whatever it's fine we grabbed lunch and
I was like we were talking about family
stuff and I was like that's a red flag
that's a red flag that's a red flag we
end up going to like the stationery
store and I'm like pick up like a candle
and I was like oh this is cute and they
look at the price and I was like I'll
put it back yeah like a normal normal
behavior and then he's like just put it
in your pocket just put it in your bag
no one's looking and I was like
No and then so I was like I don't need
it it's fine
and then I was like oh my grandpa's
birthday is coming up I found the card
it's a start I was like Daniel this cars
like four or five dollars like I'm not
gonna be five dollars for a birthday
card like whatever and he was like just
put it in your bag there was an employee
right there like with an ear shot
hearing him say like put this in your
bag I don't know you this is the first
time we're meeting like hello you know
how there's that area where you can test
pens yeah yeah so he he said wouldn't he
be romantic if you wrote your full name
and phone number on there and then your
your soul mate will go and find it and
then they'll call you and I was like or
someone could talk to me or they can
sell my personal information or they
could like hack me like there's so many
possibilities of how this could go wrong
like why would you say that and then it
was just every single store like no
one's looking so yeah that was it was
pretty bad honestly I've had like
several times where I just go on dates
like my biggest pet peeve is when people
are just constant on their phones yeah
that's all I've had like a couple dates
where girl is just constantly stare at
the phone sometimes there will be on
other dating after a while I'm gonna
take look to me what it's like I get it
but like just what do you know that's
really weird
but um there's nowhere to be found if I
still paid no at least fifteen dollars
for eggs
Oh whenever your excuse was broke I
can't help you there hey he's broken I'm
happy I think something that I've
learned as a whole the moral of the
story is besides the fact of the
afforable taste in men yeah I think that
in general I think everyone rather they
want to admit it or not on these apps
looking for love we're looking for a
deeper connection mm-hmm but I think
it's so easy for a lot of people to like
hide behind a screen and like kind of
not put their best foot forward or show
who they really are
and on the flip side of that some of
these people really put their best foot
forward and make it seem like they're
this idealized version of themselves on
these apps because you know like people
build up like these personal brands and
stuff through insta
like any other social media - it's just
the nature you know this day and age
well it's true how can like I'm a great
person you're a great person you're all
great people out there but like how are
you gonna tell that by four pictures of
bereavement exactly they need the
spirits to sound pretty normal yeah it's
pretty standard it's like you sound like
you're like not really seriously dating
yeah I'm it's hard to take these series
it's really hard yeah what are you in a
place where you're looking to be in a
relationship where you just kind of like
floating around seeing what happens I
think I'm gonna point my life where I'm
just kind of like yes going with the
flow
yeah well then definitely get off yeah
like I've always had a rough image of
what what women have to deal with when
going on these dates and I feel like you
just kind of cemented those thoughts and
those thoughts in my head yeah well yeah
I would say it listen I have I have
friends who have met their significant
others on dating apps and they've been
together for like three years and that
is the only reason why I've ever
considered like getting back on yeah but
I've gotten off because I'm like whoa
but it is possible cuz it's like a good
amount of my friends make sure I think
she covered all the bases here I think
she got it you can just cut all my parts
out you can just more room for Emily's
pen talk listen if you need help send me
a DM I'll help you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]